[Music]
america got to know amanda bynes as a
child star on shows like all that in the
amanda show nickelodeon the division of
paramount now she's 35 and a judge has
just released her from a nearly
nine-year-long conservatorship bayen
says she feels grateful and excited
about her future this case follows last
year's highly publicized end of britney
spears's conservatorship jonathan
bigliata shows us how
bindz's situation was much different
that's me
former child actress amanda bynes was
released from a court conservatorship
tuesday which controlled her life for
nearly nine years a judge granted
bynes's request to end it saying she's
done everything the court has asked over
a long period of time
although bynes was not present at the
hearing some of her former all that
co-stars were there and celebrated the
decision amanda has brought joy to so
many
people throughout her career in a
statement bynes said i would like to
thank my fans my lawyer and my parents
for their support i've been working hard
to improve my health so that i can live
and work independently and i will
continue to prioritize my well-being in
this next chapter
my name is amber can i be more popular
by age 13 bynes headlined her own show
on nickelodeon and she quickly graduated
onto bigger roles in movies like she's
the man
and easy a seems as if someone's on a
downward spiral but she has not acted
since
in 2012 and 2013 she had a series of
run-ins with the law she was arrested
and accused of driving under the
influence and possession of drugs she
was also held involuntarily in a
psychiatric hospital which ultimately
led to her being ordered into a
conservatorship controlled by her mother
i think it is interesting to everyone
that both the amanda bynes and the
britney spears conservatorship came
about from a psychiatric hold initially
attorney sarah wentz specializes in
conservatorships when you look at
britney spears and amanda bynes the
beginnings of their
conservatorship were very similar but
the way they ended uh vastly different
yeah vastly different and i think that
was because of the support of amanda
bynes parents i think that part of that
was that in the brittany case you had
people that were making money and
profiting from the conservatorship
amanda bynes's mother lynn says she's
thrilled at the ruling according to her
attorney tamar armada she's looking
forward to resuming her relationship
with amanda as a mother and daughter not
a
and
conservative
there are about 1.3 million active adult
guardianship or conservatorship cases in
the u.s
and that figure is based on the handful
of states that track those numbers
how does the future of a conservatorship
look because of these very high profile
cases i think that maybe the courts need
to look at whether or not they handle
the emergency situations where there's a
mental health crisis different from a
long-term
diagnosis of dementia for example
there's nothing to show that it's going
to be ongoing for cbs morning's jonathan
vigliotti los angeles
looks like there's a happy ending to
that story she thanked her lawyer her
fans and her parents at the end of the
day right the britney story is you know
is still going on yeah it's good good
for amanda it feels like this is the way
it's supposed to work
as opposed to the way it worked for
brittany which is the way it's not
supposed to work because people were
profiting off of britney spears and it
doesn't sound like that was happening
for me i hear these stories and i keep
going back to the impact of the industry
that it has on children's stars that's
right and how they deal with so much
that they need help and they end up
having situations like this as adults
yeah and here apparently her mom is a
big supporter yes that helps that helps